[Musique]
entretien politique avec Cyril note
membre du rassemblement national
candidat au départemental dans le canton
de Mantes-la-Jolie et candidat également
aux élections régionales et d'ailleurs
conseillère régionale sortant si bonjour
bonjour on va commencer peut-être par
les départementales vous êtes donc
candidat dans le canton de
Mantes-la-Jolie avec Mathilde andruck et
même député européenne
vous êtes face au président sortant du
conseil départemental puis vers Bédier
c'est une candidature de témoignages où
vous pensez que vous avez des chances de
gagner nous avons plusieurs objectifs
pour ces départementales c'est à la fois
d'avoir des élus puisque nous n'en avons
aucun
l'équipe de Pierre bédiat mais le Grand
Chelem comme vous le savez il y a en
2015 et un des objectifs c'est donc
d'entrer au sein de ce conseil
départemental et aussi de battre ou de
faire Bédier donc le meilleur moyen
entre guillemets de se débarrasser de
Pierre Bédier c'est de faire en sorte
que je gagne donc j'appelle tous les
Yvelinois enfin ceux qui habitent en
tout cas quand on monte à voter pour ma
candidature et celle de Maxi d'Androuet
alors dans ton boubou se débarrasser de
bien doué depuis hier Bédié il y a eu
des bouts et c'est ça où il faut le
sortir des Yvelines il faut balayer pour
restaurer la démocratie bon c'est quand
même des mots assez fort c'est violent
non ça c'est fort mais vous savez c'est
assez unanime ou si vous étudiez aussi
les discours des autres candidats à
gauche ils tiennent le même type de
discours et parfois même plus violent
que que les nôtres entre guillemets je
crois que effectivement c'est ce n'est
pas un hasard en même temps si Pierre
Bédié suscite provoque et génère ce type
de discours ça fait très longtemps qu'il
est là et c'est vrai que il a été
condamné pour corruption passive il y a
déjà quelques années et il pratique le
clientélisme a un niveau industriel et
je j'employais même l'expression
s'agissant de lui de l'islamo
clientélisme puisque il fonde en partie
c'est victoire électorales en s'appuyant
sur les communautés et notamment les
communautés les communautés musulmanes
il tient des discours au sein des au
sein des mosquées il y a une vidéo très
récente de janvier 2021 où il appelle la
communauté musulmane a le soutenir ce
que je trouve particulièrement
irresponsable et dangereux surtout dans
dans le contexte vous le savez où il y a
eu un certain nombre d'attente là
islamistes en France bien sûr mais en
particulier dans les Yvelines a
Rambouillet à Magnanville et bien sans
oublier bien sûr la décapitation de
Monsieur Samuel Paty à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine mais alors bon
ce reproche là j'ai regardé Jordan
Bardella fait exactement le même à
Valérie Vegas alors si on vous si on
vous croit il y a que des complotisme
complotistes pourquoi islamiste dans
tout le département quoi disons qu'on
dénonce beaucoup l'islamo gauchisme à
juste titre à juste raison mais il ne
faut pas oublier qu'effectivement au
centre ou à droite il y a le même type
d'élus qui par pure électoraliste
joue la carte du communautarisme et de
et de l'islamo le tennis c'est vrai de
Bruno bechisa qui est donc le maire
d'Aulnay-sous-Bois qu'on s'est régional
il a fait suite à effectivement à des
propos de Jordan Barbie qui a été
surpris pierre bélier bon pourquoi pas
l'armée alors c'est la même chose donc
tout le monde est non pas tout le monde
mais ceux qui pratiquent cela doivent
être dénoncés en l'occurrence Bruno
beciza a attaqué en justice Jordan
Bardella il attaquant diffamation et il
a perdu il a perdu ses procès voilà
parce qu'il avait invité des islamistes
radicaux dans sa commune donnée sous
bois et c'est ces personnes ont
exprimé des prêches très très dangereux
et très inquiétant quand vous parlez de
mosquée justement alors mosquée c'est
des musulmans c'est pas forcément des
islamistes
non mais c'est malgré tout dangereux et
effectivement je pense que les nos
Français nos compatriotes de confession
musulmane sont suffisamment intelligents
pour distinguer dans notre discours dans
ce que nous dénonçons
le le soutien aux islamistes radicaux ou
aux personnes les plus les plus les plus
radicales
vos confrères de Marianne pour continuer
sur le sur le sujet on mise en cause eux
aussi Pierre Bédier un cycle le préfet
actuel des Yvelines suite à
l'attentat de qui a provoqué la mort de
Samuel Paty et effectivement les
renseignements territoriaux à ce qu'il
paraît ils n'ont jamais répondu à cette
grave accusation cette grave mise en
cause mais un responsable important des
renseignements territoriaux dans les
Yvelines a été écarté peut-être parce
qu'il faisait trop bien son travail de
surveillance de des islamistes radicaux
ce qui pouvait gêner politiquement
électoralement pierre Bédié c'est le
contenu d'un article de plusieurs
articles de vous concerne de Marianne
justement que si ça touche le président
du conseil départemental le préfet la
présidente du conseil régional on se dit
à un moment voilà c'est c'est peut-être
un amalgame que vous non ce n'est pas un
amalgame et je préciserai que encore une
fois même les candidats de de gauche
lisaient encore avant de venir sur votre
plateau des les tracts de des candidats
de gauche dénonce aussi ce
communautarisme donc il n'y a pas que le
rassemblement national qu'il le fait
mais
nous le faisons nous nous privons pas de
le faire alors vous parlez de terrorisme
on vient de le voir vous parlez beaucoup
de sécurité dans votre compagnie c'était
un vrai problème que rencontre des
Français il y a d'ailleurs eu
l'agression de pouvoir médecin
à Mantes-la-Ville de docteur Claude
fossé dans le cabinet vandalisme on
sache ni par qui ni pourquoi enfin bon
c'est un fait important mais au fond la
sécurité c'est pas le problème du
Conseil départementaux est-ce que peu de
mauvaise foi dans votre campagne il y a
accès sur sur un thème sur lequel pour
le coup vous adversaires ne sont pas des
responsables certes ce ne sont pas les
principales compétences du département
les principales compétences du
département on les connaissent et la
gestion des collèges la voirie et les
prestations sociales c'est ce qui a
rappelé pierre Bédié lorsqu'il a été
interviewé par vous-même sur ce plateau
en l'occurrence juste après il a indiqué
qu'il allait déployer un plan important
de vidéo surveillance
dans la réalité vinoise vous voyez il y
a la foi il dit que c'est pas une
compétence départementale et en même
temps il s'y intéresse nous aussi nous
voulons nous intéresser au-delà des
compétences principales que j'ai rappelé
et nous devons faire le maximum pour
tout ce que nous pouvons sécuriser soit
directement soit en soutenant les
communes les communes qui elles peuvent
faire aussi leur travail dans dans ce
domaine le département aide les communes
pour créer des gymnase ou rénover des
écoles pourquoi pas le faire pour des
postes de police municipale ou des
choses de cet ordre et c'est ce que nous
voulons mettre au coeur de notre notre
action si nous sommes élus alors on va
parler un petit peu de vous vous avez
été maire de Mantes-la-Ville entre 2014
et 2020
vous étiez le seul maire à l'époque CFN
des Yvelines
et d'Île-de-France vous avez été battu
en 2020 par candidat de droite alors
jusqu'à l'heure c'était la gauche qui
qui monte la ville votre analyse à votre
avis pourquoi pourquoi vous avez été élu
et pourquoi vous avez été battu alors
j'ai été élu dans un contexte un peu
particulier
de la gauche en 2014 et il y a front
républicain en 2020 si on peut dire mais
républicain plutôt mais en l'occurrence
oui en 2014 j'ai été j'ai été élu dans
un contexte particulier d'une
quadrangulaire avec seulement 30 % des
voix 60 une voix d'écart effectivement
j'ai débattu j'ai été battu en 2020 mais
dans le cadre d'un duel cette fois et
avec 44% près de 45 % des voix
c'est-à-dire que j'ai j'ai obtenu 15% de
voix en plus donc voilà ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas un échec même si j'étais battu
malheureusement parce que les en fait
les deux listes de gauche se sont
désistés et tout le monde s'est mis
contre moi pour pour me faire battre y
compris le président du Sénat le
président du Sénat Gérard Larcher qui
est sénateur des Yvelines les présidents
du Sénat est venu faire campagne sur des
tracts et sur des affiches pour soutenir
donc ce nouveau maire de Mantes-la-Ville
et bien sûr il y avait dans pierre
Bellier qui a tout fait pour pour me
faire battre parce qu'en réalité nous
ont en réalité nous représentons la
seule la seule réelle opposition la
gauche est bien gentille d'attaquer
aujourd'hui Pierre Bédier mais si vous
regardez dans ce département
relativement faible dans en général mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est plus forte dans
certains cantons dans quand on des
Mureaux ou trap ou l'entendement mais en
réalité elle elle cogère dans certaines
intercommunalités
par exemple Grand Paris ciné Oise avec
Pierre Bédié il y a Pierre Bédier Elvis
président de la Communauté Urbaine Grand
Paris Saône et à ses côtés il y a le
maire de Magnanville qui est communiste
le maire de Limay qui est communiste le
maire des Mureaux qui est divers gauche
et en réalité le Parti Socialiste n'a
jamais réellement attaqué Pierre Bédier
et c'est très regrettable nous sommes
les seuls à l'attaquer
il y avait alors en effet des
circonstances politiques qui peuvent
expliquer votre élection et votre
défaite en 2020 mais est-ce que on
touche pas là ce qu'on appelle la
fonction tribunicienne de rassemblance
nationale c'est-à-dire que la parole est
forte mais au fond quand vous êtes
au pouvoir si je peux dire encore que il
faut être juste c'est pas le cas de tous
les mers il y a des mères beaucoup de
merde en ce moment-là qui ont été réunis
mais est-ce que au fond est-ce que la
vidéo des gens changent vraiment
à la région Paca dans le sud-est ou
Thierry Mariani a de très sérieuses
chances de gagner pour pour plein de
raisons le fait que ça soit quelqu'un
justement qui viennent de la droite dit
très républicaine ça pose pas un
problème non au contraire
vous savez beaucoup il y a un certain
nombre il y a un certain nombre
de têtes de liste je pense à Sébastien
Chenu aussi dans les hauts de France qui
viennent qui viennent de la droite
républicaine c'est tout simplement pour
montrer que nous sommes totalement
ouverts que nous ne sommes pas une secte
André cottarade pour la région
auvergne-rhône-alpes vient de la gauche
donc en l'occurrence tous les tous les
patriotes sincères sont sont les
bienvenus mais j'aimerais revenir sur la
sur la région PACA et nos chances
réelles de gagner nous allons peut-être
gagner cette région et sans doute la
gagner aussi parce que
Renaud Muselier est de connivence en
réalité avec les macronistes avec le
gouvernement actuel et ça me permet de
revenir dans le département des Yvelines
vous avez fait remarquer juste titre à
Pierre Bédié que un certain nombre de
macronistes étaient sur ces listes voilà
donc députée en tant que suppléante moi
je trouve ça totalement scandaleux je me
souviens des tracts de 2015 ou très
clairement
pierre-bédier indiquait qu'il faisait
partie de la majorité des
départementales mais l'opposition
nationale aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
casier
est complice avec le gouvernement de
d'Emmanuel Macron et il est donc
complice de son bilan qui est désastreux
à la fois sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et sur la crise économique qui
ne manquera pas de survenir
justement sur ce sur cette question-là
pour ceux qui font mettre de la
politique partout que au niveau d'une
Berry dans département il y a pas une
entente qui est possible entre des gens
qui veulent voilà une action en faveur
des habitants vous savez ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a un peu choqué dans la
l'interview de Pierre Bédié c'est qu'il
a essayé de se faire passer pour un
gestionnaire des bonheurs alors que
c'est un politicien madre rotor et sans
scrupule qui lui fait justement
systématiquement de la politique il a
dit que le président du département
était là pour aider les maires il a aidé
peut-être tous les maires sauf celui de
Mantes-la-Ville et tous ceux en réalité
qui représentent une opposition ou tout
simplement qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
lui donc nous en l'occurrence il nous
avons mis sur notre tract que nous
voulions restaurer la démocratie c'est
parce que nous voulons dépenser
l'argent des hypnois l'argent public
dans leur intérêt sans tenir compte de
l'étiquette politique des maires par
exemple merci Cyril note merci à vous
[Musique]